hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 15 something they need with that
something I guess being all of
Oceanside's guns which they took in
exchange for something some of the
people of Oceanside deviance
you're not leaving us any nope see you
later Rachel now a lot in this episode
felt like setup for next week's season
finale but there were definitely some
interesting details and connections to
the Walking Dead comics so I'm gonna get
into all of those and my theories on
some of the questions you might have had
coming out of this episode let's get
started with the opening images so this
episode opens on two groups making their
way to Oceanside a bunch of soulless
monsters looking to feed on the
community and these walkers on the beach
kidding aside I like how the opening
shot here parallels last week's episode
with an out-of-focus figure stepping
into a close-up followed by a montage
that compares two types of people going
after what they need one looking to
satisfy an impulsive need without really
thinking about it at all and the other
looking to satisfy a long-term need
while thinking about it very carefully
and I love the look of these Beach
walkers here they're porous and spongy
covered in barnacles and seaweed and
coral cool and it looks like Greg
Nicotero was taking a cue from the
design of Davy Jones crew and Pirates of
the Caribbean Dead Man's Chest and
actually these walkers have a similar
backstory to those undead pirates they
were also passengers on this boat which
washed up on the shore and I feel like
that had to be recent otherwise Cindy
and Rachel would have noticed it when
they were on the beach in episode 6 and
I just love this idea of a ghost ship
filled with walkers drifting around in
the sea like I feel like this is one way
the Walking Dead could connect to fear
The Walking Dead even though this takes
place on the west coast and I'm pretty
sure we never saw this boat in
particularly okay moving on past the
credits we see Maggie at the hilltop
doing some gardening with this guy
Eduardo now there could be some sparks
here kind of like when we saw Maggie and
Glenn gardening together last season and
Carol and Ezekiel planting the tree a
few episodes back gently patting dirt
mmm this guy needs a cold shower but
Maggie's having none of it her tone here
is all business and even kind of morbid
using the tarp to speed along the plant
lifecycle you want more so put out
shoots for the last freeze that way we
pull back the tarp the dinette
he saves another Emma's waiting and this
is kind of a total opposite of the
farming tips that Maggie's father
Hershel gave Rick back in season 4 whose
will bristles will take root we'll have
a whole new plant so in that moment
Hershel was an optimist implying that
even when things break they can still
regrow basically that idea of it's never
too late to change which is aligned
Maggie says in this episode and while I
think Maggie still believes that in this
moment her optimism is sobered the
deaths of her father and her husband
Glen have turned her into more realist
knowing that sometimes things are just
gonna die and it's best to rip it off
like a band-aid or a tart also we notice
that Gregory is eavesdropping on this
conversation and two details in
particular threaten him one the fact
that Eduardo calls Maggie Bosley and to
the fact that Maggie wants to plant a
blueberry bush that can live for 40
years implying that she intends to stay
at the hilltop for a very long time okay
moving on to Rick's group now in case
you missed what exactly Rick's plan was
for Oceanside the idea was to have
terrorists sneak in since she's really
the only one who knows the layout of the
place and then that would begin a count
down giving Tara a limited amount of
time to convince Netanya to surrender
peacefully but if that negotiation took
too long
Daryl and Jesus would trigger these
explosives which are the same ones that
they stole from the savior blockade back
in episode 9 and those explosives would
scare the people out of the village
where Michonne positioned as a sniper
could heard them using warning shots and
then Rick could hold them hostage while
they looted their armory now a lot of
you pointing out that Rick is kind of
acting like negan here stealing people's
guns and actually think that those
parallels go even deeper and they're
intentional but also this episode
specifically calls back other decisions
made by past Walking Dead villains like
the governor and the people from
terminus asking us to compare leadership
styles and the motivations behind those
decisions but I'll point those out as we
go okay moving on to Sasha
whose infiltration of the sanctuary
apparently ended with her capture and
honestly I'm a little bummed that this
happened off camera and we didn't get to
see it but this scene that it led to
with David is pretty great it's taken
directly from issue 117 in the comics
with rapey Davy the Savior assaulting a
different but similar character Holly
whom the show seems to be replacing with
Sasha and everything from David's creepy
dialog to negan bursting in and stabbing
Davida neck goes down pretty closely to
how it does in the comics sorry yeah
yeah
we are not monster but there are a few
changes from the comics to like for one
the comics include a line from negan
that goes deeper into why negan has a
hard line against rape he talks about
the bigger picture saying this war
however long it lasts is a means to an
end when the dust settles and we've won
ultimately we have to work with these
people we want a community that can
accomplish things together that healing
cannot begin if we have sunk to such
inking human levels and this is
important because in real world history
rape was and still is used as an
instrument of war with invading armies
raping the women to completely
demoralize and destabilize the Society
of the losing side but negan doesn't
want to completely destroy his enemies
he wants to control them and bring them
into his worldview and he believes that
that kind of indoctrination can work
through fear tactics and killing random
people but not by leaving them with this
deep-rooted resentment also I think
negan's anti-rape policy is meant to
contrast the governor in Woodbury which
this moment reminds us of with this
other deviation from the comics that
phrase go to hell is also what Maggie
told the governor when he assaulted her
so while the governor was a reckless
monster who acted impulsively negan is a
more calculated monster whose evil
follows a code also notice how this seen
repeatedly mentions that sasha is tied
up with rope sure Stoll canta fun and
interesting things you can do with rope
I think that this is a subtle reminder
of that same last episode when Rosita
taught Sasha how to tie a knot and I
kind of a feeling that we're gonna see
Sasha used that rope as the weapon that
she's seeking and before I move on I
like this little detail that when negan
realizes that Sasha was in the lineup
seen in the first episode he recalls it
by doing these same iconic negan lean
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is actually aware of
this gesture and I love how obsessed he
is with it okay moving on this next
scene with Eugene seems to shoot down
those theories that Eugene's loyalty to
negan is just an act like he explains
his rationale no believed
be brave and I could be a survivor like
Abraham was eugene is referring to one
of the last conversations he had with
abraham last season I've changed adapted
I'm a survivor but then seeing that same
brave survivor get killed in the woods
scared him so much that now he's doing
everything he can to avoid that fear and
stay safe
even if it means holding his nose and
working for negan so the good news is
negan still doesn't really like the
Savior's and if that balance the power
shifts I could see him returning to his
friends side but at the same time it's
not like he's working on some secret
long-term plan to subvert negan from
under his nose like Eugene is smart but
he just seems too afraid to be that bold
I also find it interesting that Eugene
says this being here means I'll never
have to again neither will you if you
just say yes so the phrase say yes was
the same words that Jadis and Rick used
earlier this season to end their
bargaining say yes basically stop being
stubborn and say yes to a deal that
isn't ideal for you but will let us move
forward I actually have a deeper theory
for why Eugene uses these words in
particular that I'll get to later but
before I move on it's interesting that
sasha is left with this dilemma to kill
a walker in a Cell
that's another parallel between negan
and the governor who left Andrea in a
locked room with Milton as a walker
forcing her to use pliers to try to fend
them off now this scene between Maggie
and Gregory features the title of this
episode with Maggie explaining where
Sasha Rosita and Daryl went
they're looking for something they need
now on the surface that need is revenge
against negan satisfying their selfish
impulsive desire regardless of how it
could affect others but really when you
think about it that's not a need so much
as it's a want and most of the
characters this episode needs something
more control over their own lives and
real influence and power
that's why negan forbids a society of
raping and pillaging well he's cool with
pillaging and why in this scene
Gregory backs down from stabbing Maggie
in the back because he knows that
impulse decision will probably make him
lose even more power this scene also
reveals that Gregory has apparently
never taken down a walker before
something that he lied about to the
hilltoppers and that facade is something
that he's in common with another leader
nearby Ezekiel at the kingdom who
purports his own false identity to his
people the difference is
people still respect him maybe it's a
tiger moving on to Oceanside I like how
de Tanya's eyes linger for a second on
the corner of her home where there are
still bullet holes from the shootout
with Tara in Episode six and I like how
this suggests that Oceanside's wounds
from their encounter with terrorists
still remain and they've come back to
haunt them when Tara returns and maybe
I'm just reading into things but check
out this moment between Tara and Cindy
they killed my friends they killed my
girlfriend they took us over they took
everything from us I see you in that
reaction Chad Cindy no girlfriend huh
and Tara keeps checking her watch
because she knows her negotiations with
Netanya are taking too long
time's up and now Rick's Plan B with the
explosives kicks in now again I know
this whole plan to steal Oceanside's
guns makes Rick and his people look a
bit like negan and the Savior's and yeah
scaring them with these explosions
reminds me a lot of the governor's
warning shot at the prison and Michonne
sniper fire controlling where the women
promotion side can run is similar to the
way that the people of terminus boxed in
Rick's crew and these parallels are
valid but there's one key difference
here Rick doesn't end up killing any of
these people like negan he doesn't want
to demoralize his enemies he wants to
recruit that but unlike negan not one
drop of blood has to be spilled
Tara's gun was empty and even these
explosives aren't used to hurt people
they're abused to control traffic which
if you remember was actually their
intended purpose under fat Joey's
redirect plan but when it comes to these
parallels between Rick and negan Robert
Kirkman has actually said that the
character of negan is who Rick would be
if he had just had different experiences
early on in the apocalypse so while the
two men both steal guns and kill doctors
and order people to kneel negan is
coming from a different place like
remember earlier he told Sasha that we
all got [ __ ] that could mean that
negan's tragic backstory from the comics
which I won't spoil here is going to be
revealed as a key motivator for his
whole savagery meanwhile the key
motivator for Rick is something a bit
more hopeful Carl and Judith both of
whom he almost lost but miraculously
found their way back to him which was
his major inspiration ever since he led
Alexandria to clear that hoard last
season and I think that's why we get a
similar cooperative moment when Rick and
the oceanside women clear these beach
walkers
okay checking back in with Sasha and
Egon Sasha shows that she's willing to
play ball by putting down rapey David
Walker and leaving the knife there in
his skull now obviously this is an angle
Sasha's playing but notice when negan
says this line Oh birdie told me that
Rick and the rest year people are up to
no good
so negan just revealed that he is a spy
a mole somewhere in Rick's operation
so who's the birdie now it could be just
some Savior that he sent to spy on them
from afar as they move from place to
place but I feel like this is a mystery
that's gonna be revealed so let's run
through a few suspects my first thought
is Gregory who definitely seems like
he's headed to the sanctuary to betray
Maggie but Gregor he hasn't gone there
yet and he hasn't said anything to simon
either so I feel like negan's probably
not talking about him it could also be
Eugene or Dwight who seem like they're
playing both sides of the fence but as
far as we know neither of them has been
around Rick ever since he starred in it
for war dr. Harlan Carson is another
possible Birdie negan has him in his
control now and maybe Carson spilled the
beans about Maggie and her knife lessons
after some intense interrogation or
something I feel like it could also be a
minor character from one of the
communities like Eduardo from the
hilltop or like Jerry wait no not Jerry
it's too jolly
I mean Meegan's a little birdie could
also be literally birdie from the
hilltop like her name is birdie
that would make negan the ultimate roll
but really negan mentioned Rick and not
Maggie so my theory is that this little
birdie is someone none of us ever should
have trusted anyway jatis she keeps
[ __ ] around with Rick on the number
of guns that she wants and she's a
general garbage person and the name
jatis kind of sounds like Judas to me
also I think Eugene echoing the say yes
line might be a clue that she has a
secret arrangement with negan so part of
me feels like this season of The Walking
Dead could end like season 1 of Game of
Thrones with Rick as Ned Stark marching
up to overthrow negan Joffrey assuming
that he has the city watch the
scavengers on his side and then jatis
Littlefinger is gonna pull a knife to
his throat and say I told you not to
take my cat statue or she would say it
like told you I did cat statue don't
take that could be totally wrong about
this we'll see in the finale now real
quick in this scene with Gregory and Cal
as they plan to make their way to the
sanctuary some of you have pointed out
how Gregory's liquor glass teleports
from his left side to his right and I
was gonna try
spin this as Gregory losing his mind as
his power slips away from him like
Macbeth but honestly guys it's just an
editing gap like my interpretations are
only 95 percent [ __ ] and Sasha's
attempts to trick Eugene into giving her
a weapon to kill herself with but to
actually kill negan with backfires when
Eugene gives her the poison pill that he
made back in episode 11 so Sasha is
really at the end of a rope here but I'm
curious that the show really is taking
Sasha on Holly's storyline in the comics
which I don't want to spoil here or if
they're planning to deliberately deviate
from that storyline we will see you next
episode and after Rick and his people
leave with all of Oceanside's guns Tara
leaves Rachel with their own little
birdie which is another callback to
episode 6 and that brings us to our
closing images at Alexandria where it
turns out the figure that appeared to
recede in the shadows outside the
sanctuary last episode was actually
Dwight providing Rick with a little
birdie from negan's operation and notice
how this takes place in the prison cell
completing Dwight's character arc from
one prison cell in the sanctuary in
episode three episode that was called
the cell to this new prison cell in
Alexandria and Rick completes his
transition by forcing Dwight on its
knees just like how Dwight and his
people forced Rick on his knees at the
beginning of the season but while it
kind of seems impulsive of Dwight to
switch sides like this this is actually
a well-thought-out strategic decision
fulfilling a need
Dwight knows that he will always feel
kind of like a prisoner under negan and
that goodbye letter from his wife Sherry
challenged him to find his soul and by
offering his services to Rick he's
giving them something they need see what
I did there cuz something they need is a
title of the episode and as we head into
the season finale next week a couple
lingering questions who do you guys
think negan's little birdie is he
already went through some possible
suspect I'm curious who you guys think
it is or if we're even ever gonna find
out and - who do you think this is I'm
Rick and - what do you think is Rick's
biggest risk as he prepares to confront
negan is it the spy in his ranks Gregory
betraying Maggie
jatis and the garbage people screwing
him over Eugene offering his ammo
manufacturing and general creativity to
negan or whatever negan has in store for
Sasha or maybe some other secret weapon
that negan has up his sleeve let me know
what you think in the comments and check
out my other breakdowns of seasons
episodes thanks for watching if you
liked this video please hit like and
subscribe to new rock stars also please
share this video and if you really like
new rock stars you can contribute to us
on patreon thank you so much to all of
our current patrons you guys are the
best especially you Kelly hopper you can
hit me up on twitter at EA boss with any
thoughts or theories you have on The
Walking Dead or follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos ok thanks for watching bye
you